[Music]
okay
Oh
[Music]
let her go
I don't ask twice
yep
you're from shield never heard of it
hi everyone its charlie we got a brand
new agents of shield season 6 trailer
they just had their WonderCon panel
explaining what's going on with season 6
it's been renewed through season 7 if
you guys didn't know the premiere date
is gonna be in the middle of May after
Avengers end game for a very specific
reason so I'll explain the Avengers
infinity war an Avengers end game of all
this and what's going on because
obviously they're relying on some really
big twist because original Coulson died
after last season of agents of shield so
this is not that Coulson we've only got
a little while left before Avengers end
game is actually here so there's a new
round of that imax ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
agents of shield moment on the video
even though they don't have a title card
during this they revealed during the
panel this takes place one year after
the events of the agents of shield
finale in the Avengers infinity war snap
which both kind of happened around the
same time so even though Avengers end
game picks up well after the events of
Avengers infinity war in the snap and
you sort of see them aged in the trailer
you see black widows hair grow out so
clearly there's a bunch of time jumps
during avengers endgame but they haven't
confirmed when that actually ends
because there's a lot of time-travel
theories and about them ending things in
the moments before the original snap so
that everything continues on and pepper
and Tony get married when they said they
were gonna get married because that was
the whole point of that scene so
regardless of what the date is
when Avengers end game ends this takes
place after that so that they don't have
to trample on Avengers end game or give
away big spoilers for how everybody
comes back the shield team is still
grieving Coulson Mack is the new
director of shield you see him getting
instructions and guidance from that
digital Coulson back up that he left for
him before he passed away even though
you don't see her during this clip Daisy
has a brand new quake suit this is what
it looks like she said that her
character is still grieving for Coulson
but a year is gone by so they sort of
continued on with their lives
you see yo-yo with her mechanical arms
that she got from the comics she's had
those for a while now they give Mae the
big CG action scene of the truck porting
through you can actually see it even
looks like it's coming through a portal
in the evil version of Coulson stepping
off the back too
skew his team member who looks like a
slightly more edgy goth version of Daisy
so you can kind of see what they're
setting up here you have evil Coulson
with his team versus the shield agents
in all of Coulson's old friends they
screen the entire first episode at
WonderCon I was not there to see it so I
don't know how many big things they
revealed or how much backstory about
this alternate version of Coulson they
just confirmed that this is not our
Coulson from a different point in time
like it's not a time-travel explainer
they didn't say that he's not a scroll
but I think the long-term payoff for
this is that he becomes the new main
version of Coulson and things get more
complicated like they want him to be a
very complex character so he's not just
a simple bad guy out to get them if it
winds up being an alternate universe
explainer like he's an alternate
universe version of Coulson then it'll
probably be a much bigger story because
why would he need to come into our
reality so I don't think that he's gonna
be a life model decoy or a robot in
disguise or anything like that I think
it's a genuine flesh and blood Coulson
he'll just have to wind up working with
the original shield team members and
because he has no emotional connection
to them like he doesn't know what shield
is he doesn't know who any of these
people are but they still care about
their Coulson they'll just use that for
a lot of drama and tension within the
group so early prediction evil Coulson
eventually working with the shield team
agents trying to live up to original
Coulson's greatness like imagine them
challenging him are Coulson did all
these great things look at the life that
he lead you should all this MCU clips of
him interacting with the Avengers
characters hindering the Captain Marvel
movie your floating fortress falls from
the sky where is my disadvantage in that
conviction
I don't think so that's what it does
they make him feel like he's an inferior
version of Coulson so he just tries to
eventually live up to that greatness
there are 13 episodes in this season
Clark Gregg said that he thinks that
they're gonna end the show after season
7 so that be next year but if the
WonderCon panel Jeff lobe is like we're
not planning on this being the ending we
might get more episodes than that so
they might do the arrow thing where they
get an abbreviated season 8 and that's
when they wrap everything up but just
because they're rolling hard on the evil
alternate version of Coulson doesn't
mean that original Coulson won't ever
come back because death is not the end
in the Marvel Universe there's so many
different planes of existence so many
ways to explain how he can come back but
whatever twist they use I don't think
that's gonna trample on the ending of
season 5 because that was meant to pay
off a lot of emotional arcs he'd made
the bargain with Ghost Rider he'd
finally got together with May so they
sort of sent him off into the sunset and
a really nice ending so I don't think
that they would completely trample on
that by just bringing him right back so
unless they come out and say otherwise I
think the dark version of Coulson is
here to stay for a long time they're
sort of trading on a couple of ideas in
Avengers in Game two alternate realities
in reforming the team albeit with
slightly different pieces so like I said
they're trying not to spoil avengers
endgame which is why they're waiting til
after it comes in theaters to premiere
the season they did a much better job of
introducing the idea of multiple
realities and how people can phase shift
between those during ant-man and the
wasp especially that post-credit scene
where he's collecting all that energy I
shouldn't unit activates when you
decouple it it should automatically
start absorbing quantum healing
particles also make sure you stay out of
the tardigrade fields they're cute but
they'll eat you and don't get sucked
into a time vortex we won't be able to
save you
there's so much we didn't know about
this place Henry world upon world entire
civilizations far more than we ever
theorist it's okay
[Music]
passing through we stake now claim
yeah
but once you have a chance to see
Avengers endgame at the end of this
month it'll crystallize some of your
concepts about what's possible in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the story
twists that they'll use that for in
future movies and TV shows I know
everybody's rolling hard on Scrolls in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe now when
are they coming back because they were
good characters during Captain Marvel
Kevin Feige came out after that movie
and said no they're definitely evil
Scrolls out there that we haven't met
yet that would do something in the vein
of Secret Invasion so was just his way
of letting you know that yes we're
totally gonna include that twist in
future MCU movies during the Captain
Marvel movies because that's where the
scrolls debuted but also in other big
movies and probably TV shows eventually
I don't know if there's going to be a
Coulson cameo during avengers endgame
because it does seem like they're
revisiting the events of the first
Avengers movie when they're wearing
those special quantum suits you see
motion capture dots all over them with
those special risk devices so it seems
like whatever this is going to be it'll
be a heavy visual effects sequence but
if there was ever a time to bring
Coulson back for a cameo it would be
sometime during that if there's going to
be some time travel element during the
movie still a lot of questions about how
they accomplish all this stuff so just
remember they'll be using all the
different concepts that you've seen in
previous Marvel films multiverse and
time travel are just a couple of those
things
time travel is like the brand new thing
that they've introduced via Doctor
Strange and he's really only used time
travel in a very light localized way
like just turning back the events of
this localized area of New York City
during the big battle at the end of his
movie then on a visual level of just
showing him sitting there seeing through
all the different timelines we haven't
quite got to the point where someone
physically time-travels back into the
past or into the future so I just think
that we're gonna see a little bit of
that during avengers endgame because
when they all say whatever it takes they
mean literally whatever it takes so
every major concept sci-fi twist you
could think of post all your evil
Coulson theories in the comments below
and let me know do you actually think
that Clark Gregg is gonna have a small
cameo during avengers endgame because
they have said that they're gonna
include pretty much every big character
that they have in the MCU in that film
in some way or another but it's
WonderCon weekend there'll be a bunch
more Marvel and DC stuff posting I'll
probably do a new Avengers endgame video
soon there's new Game of Thrones
tomorrow leave all your requests in the
comments below
here for my New Avengers in-game trailer
Easter eggs and click here for the
Batman hush movie trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]